good morning how are doing today
cool actually it's very it was very
stressful Monday till like 10 for me
because last year we had a very very bad
times during registration this time I
think you it went much smoother so right
now we're just we are sorghum eyes are
gonna look at the conference and like
fill the atmosphere with pleasure
so we're gonna start in a short minute
with our first keynote but before that I
have a shirt presentation for you about
my data who we are exactly exactly and
what you're gonna experience during
these two days so my rate is Meetup
that is run in Warsaw since 2015 last
year because like we had always so many
people in our meetups we said okay let's
make a conference make it international
and see what happens and lastly we have
like over 400 people in a in this room
actually and after that so many people
asked us okay that was very good even we
really enjoyed it so why not make it
another one so yeah and this is another
one and we're almost there right we've
our talks and and speakers so let's work
anyway
okay what you gonna experience during
this two days for keynotes 42 talks and
ignite talks so and really really
encourage you to submit your topics for
the ignite talks it's very very
interesting part of each conference and
you have to afterparty of Beasley today
we're gonna experiment with one more
thing so which is called graphical
graphical recording and there is one
lady over here somewhere that will be
like sketching on their notebook like on
her on her iPad and will be signing up
towards the graphical recordings of some
of the talks so you'll find that on the
Facebook probably and Twitter and in the
recordings of the sample talks
going to be released like in two months
or something like that you can connect
or you can you can chat you can back
back channel with this tag PwC 2018 on
Twitter you can find us on Facebook
meetup on meetup.com which is our
basically our primary website or our
primary service ignite talks ignite
attacks this kind of a short
presentation of everyone like that want
to present something like five minutes
we can do 10 minutes enough like that
that will present their project there's
something interesting they're working on
and that our experience shows this is
very very interesting time because the
people that are not usually talking on a
conferences they talk about their
projects and usually there's it's so so
interesting their secure code you can
find it also well this could kill corn
on the on the screens around the venue
where you can submit actually this is
this your ignite talks so I really
encourage you to do that and today after
this day full of talks you're gonna have
an after party it's very close here
beans about her end own so free beer
some snacks as well and lots of people
probably gonna be like the only only
people that in this in this place so
we're gonna be very very funny it was
actually very fun last year actually who
brought this conference to you because
my data is being brought by the
community so actually we're not at all
organization we're not Society
so all these people are in the screen
this is the program community that also
responsible for actually the the program
the scheduled this conference and this
organized community so Camila got the
Mukesh come and Yaqoob ma tell me how
from the program committee and these
people are actually responsible for
everything that you can see here in this
in this room so and in like on the
websites and all stuff all the
communication so
kamilla Evelina Marta Sujata Magda Clara
Wojtek and Philippe so great round of
applause for all these people because
they're doing that as a community
actually for free
totally so and how is it housed
organized because we are our legal
entity is not focused that is providing
there is funding open-source project
within the Zetas communities where
everything that all the profit that
we're making on this conference goes to
the open source actually so as I said
the community is working here for for
granted actually this concert is also
backed by our partners so Samsung Boston
Consulting Group BCG gamma that guru I -
tv.com and in guro
and we had some community partners as
well so such as girls in tech and taxa
Phi so and that's all from my side